[Applaudissements]
un stade en hommage à ce petit de la
ville devenu grand le terrain d'honneur
du complexe sportif de
Verneuil-sur-Seine porte désormais le
nom de Matteo Guendouzi joueur de
l'Olympique de Marseille c'est pourtant
bien au PSG que le natif de Poissy a
débuté le football pensionnaire de la
préformation du club parisien
l'international français a été hébergé à
Verneuil et évoluait sur les terrains de
la commune il a même été élève au
collège Jean Zay je suis resté pendant
trois années donc j'ai fait ma cinquième
quatrième troisième ici au collège et
bah sur ces terrains c'est là où on
s'entraînait pareil pendant trois
saisons avec la avec la préformation
donc moi ça avait ça fait quoi 9-10 ans
maintenant donc pas mal de très bons
souvenirs qui qui reviennent et à 24
heures avoir un stade à son nom c'est
quand même quelque chose de très beau et
j'en suis vraiment très fier le
footballeur a également reçu la médaille
de la ville devant 150 invités la
municipalité a souhaité ainsi valoriser
le parcours de ce jeune vernolien ça a
été presque deux ans de travail pour
pouvoir monter cette journée évidemment
il a un agenda surchargé mais surtout il
y avait plein de questions qui se
posaient sur comment on le faisait
comment on organiser on a dû passer une
délibération au conseil municipal et je
me réjouis vraiment que la majorité est
portée ce projet afin de donner des
étoiles dans les yeux des enfants
plus tard
de l'année
une après-midi du 7 juin 2023 dont les
jeunes du club se souviendront longtemps
Matteo gain Douzi a assisté à leur
entraînement pendant une petite heure
c'est un très bel hommage effectivement
pour pour le club pour lui-même avoir
son monde dans son club d'origine c'est
c'est exceptionnel il m'a sauté depuis
plein de bien pour l'avenir bien
travailler à l'école et de continuer le
foot si ça me plaît franchement j'ai été
ému c'était quelque chose que je pense
qu'il va marquer toute ma vie et
franchement ça a été un moment
incroyable l'occasion donc d'échanger
avec les footballeurs en herbe et de se
prêter ensuite à l'exercice de la séance
de dédicace ça fait extrêmement plaisir
parce que tu les vois avec le sourire tu
les vois avec la banane je les ai vu ce
matin au collège aussi c'était vraiment
tous heureux donc s'ils peuvent avoir
des des exemples pas que moi mais
d'autres mais d'autres joueurs ou
d'autres personnes c'est vraiment
quelque chose de beau pour que continuer
d'avancer dans dans le futur
l'après-midi c'est conclu par un match
de football pas de gaine Douzi sur le
terrain qui jouait les coachs pour cette
fois mais les jeunes n'avaient bien sûr
qu'un nom à la bouche